跟我老公都是二婚，
我37，
然后他是49，
然后有一个孩子6岁，
现在他外面就是有负债，
大概200个，
之前是在我我们婚蜜他女儿要出国，
他前妻借贷款了，
他大概100个，
然后为了他女儿出国，
还有一个就是他帮他女儿还房贷，
大概57万，
这些就是他写了欠条给他前妻的，
他认了，
还有就是她外面还有这个小大爷发90个，
那我们现下闺蜜有一套房子，
她婚前有一套房子，
我问一下你啊，
她们在跟你结婚之前，
和他前妻他俩一起贷款100万，
且这个钱用于他女儿出国，
用于他帮他女儿还房贷，
这些你有证据吗？
他前妻去银行贷的这个款，
然后他认，
他这得前妻写业借条，
他是认这个钱不是用他名字去贷的，
这个钱实际上是前期贷款，
但是你老公认为这个钱该他来出，
所以你老公给他的前期打的欠条是这意思吗？
对，
他现在是经济紧张了，
也相当是失业了，
他且他前妻写了一个57万的欠条，
又写了100万的欠条，
然后他前妻现在起，
然后让某燕报我名下的那套房子给查封了，
有两套查封了，
他婚之前有一套是他爸妈在住，
查封了，
同时现在名下这一套在查封了，
明。
老是指你和你现在的老公共同名字都在上面有一套被查了是吧，
那他自己样，
而且就是婚结婚的财产，
哦，
好，
你也太冤了，
姐妹啊，
前妻的孩子留学也好，
买房子也好，
跟你一毛钱关系都没有，
你接着说你现在是个啥情况，
我现在就是之前感情还挺好，
但这个去欠条借钱不是背着我就去年的时候才发现的，
然后他前妻现在是从今年呢，
好像是七八月份起多长的，
就是这事年，
那么我现在就是都不知道自己在怎么，
嗯，
你和你的老公总共结婚是几年呀，
今年孩子现在6岁，
然后你自己在此之前的那一段婚姻有孩子吗？
孩子。
孩子给男方了是吗？
对哦，
现在你老公是失业状态，
没有失业之前他是干什么，
大概一年挣多少钱呢？
做工程啊，
还是结婚了，
那你现在是干什么的呀？
那现在解封之后都是在家里给他家庭首付嘛，
你现在自己手上有多少个存款呀，
我本来有他像那个，
哎，
去年的时候因为他这个失业的没钱了嘛，
我把这个钱全部拿出来还房贷了，
那个学费呀，
那你现在等于是没什么存款了，
而你们所有的共同财产就是那一套登记在男方名下的正在还房贷并且被拿封的房子，
嗯嗯，
除了那套房子之外就没别的东西是不是？
嗯，
那你娘家是干什么的呀？
爸妈是干啥的呀？
我很子普通的，
我帮不了的兄弟姊妹呢，
也帮不了。
嗯，
他前妻跟他为啥离婚啊，
好像感情破裂了。
还好你是普通家庭，
但凡你要跟我说你家里有点钱的话，
我感觉人家这前面两口子是在做局育，
是在坑，
你觉得像不像不像在坑你对我一开始觉得他可能是他妈在坑我了，
现在看这个样子，
可们又不一像，
他前天也给他写作了哟，
你现在希望龙飞律师帮你解答的问题是什么呢？
我就想着，
呃，
这个房子他啊，
不是起住了吗？
那我想这个房子能不能保住。
我我以为在去年12月份的时候，
他给我写了一个公证，
就正常子给我，
你有没有去办过户，
没有这个事儿我给你分析一下吧啊，
第一他的前妻去贷款，
然后给孩子出国啊，
给孩子买房，
第二，
你老公承诺这个钱还给前妻，
确实是你老公他自己自愿的行为，
他要这么承诺，
并且他要打这个欠条，
他要说这个钱该他承担的话，
在法律上是没有人能阻止他的，
你这头能争取的是什么呢？
因为你跟你老公你俩是合法的夫妻，
那么你老公在这七年当中挣的所有的钱都有你的份，
就说他在七年当中啊，
总共就挣了这么一套房，
假设这套房就价值100万，
那么其中有50万应该是属于你的财产，
前提条件是如果你跟他离婚的话，
你要跟他不离婚的话，
这100万是属于你们夫妻共同的财产，
且不分份额的，
就是现在你们不离婚的状态下，
你也说不清这100万当中，
这套房当中你该占多少，
你理解这个逻辑吧，
嗯，
好。
那现在是，
嗯，
你老公欠他前妻的钱，
这个事儿他自己也心甘情愿，
他也不提任何反驳意见，
那你老公欠他前妻钱这个事儿就板上钉钉了，
他就是欠，
现在该拿什么钱来还这个100多万的这个欠钱呢？
该拿你老公自己的个人财产来还，
而不是你们夫妻的共同财产来还啊，
比如你们的共同财产假设啊价值100万，
那么其中我们就说有50万属于他的个人财产，
那么他要还债的话，
也只能动用他的个人财产去还债，
通过他不是我是说呀，
他分钱帮他，
哎，
你这种情况呢，
既然说当时已经公正了，
把婚后的这套房子给你是吧，
你现在想要去对抗他的前妻的话，
那你也去打个官司啊，
但是你这膝盖呢，
呃，
划分两头说，
就是你打这个官司会不会影响到你和你老公的这个夫妻感情，
因为本来你也是靠老公养着的，
本来是靠他养着这个家的，
你现在如果你不打算跟他分开，
你打这个官司又破坏了夫妻感情，
将来他挣钱他不交到你手里了，
那这个就不划算，
他一直赚钱都没交到我的手里，
他的钱就是有多少我也搞不清楚，
其实我们感情也基本也破裂了，
那现在也有执行意思，
律师建议我就是马上起诉离婚那。
我问你啊，
假设咱们分手了，
跟他分开了之后，
咱们的生活怎么安排呢？
就住哪儿呢？
孩子归谁呢？
生活费怎么来源，
靠什么呢？
因为平时啊，
考察还行政销售这些都没问题，
这几个月找工作还是很好找的，
嗯，
但是孩子，
如果我带着孩子呢？
我问你啊，
婚后你俩买的这套房啊，
一个月还贷款还多少呀？
这房子因为之前他卖经济好，
还贷款还一万四买的房贷是高在那个走出去假设特别好的一种结局，
说你的老公也挺心疼孩子的，
也挺心疼你的，
就把这个房子就是给你了，
然后由你来还房贷，
那你能接得下来吗这个锅。
把房子租出去，
可以租的5000，
先少5000，
然后贷我房贷，
我觉得我觉得有点问题，
王飞律师，
我没有恶意啊，
我是帮你来算这个账啊，
假设这个房子租出去5000块钱，
那么就还差7000的房贷，
差7000的房贷就意味着什么呢？
意味着你的工资收入一个月最起码得一万五才行，
原因是什么？
因为你还得吃，
还得喝，
还得用，
还得租房子，
还得带孩子，
孩子你想要还是不想要，
就纠结这个问题，
想要孩子，
因为孩子是我一直带着父母钱啊，
就如果你想要孩子的话，
可能你的工资水平一万五都不一定能打得住，
你的工资水平你可能得你一万八你才能打得住，
其中啊7000用来还房贷，
然后剩下的1万你和孩子最起码得租个房子，
咱就说2000块钱是吧，
还剩下个八九千块钱，
因为孩子6岁了，
到上学的年纪了，
那就难免有各种学杂费的支出，
甚至有的时候还要报个什么课外班啊什么的。
所以我们客观的分析一下，
就是你如果去找工作，
能不能找一个一万五左右的工作能够覆盖，
而且这个前提条件是你这个房子租出去，
一个月租5000块钱，
还不能断租，
但凡哪天断租了之后，
你一个月的工资就覆盖不了房贷，
覆盖不了这个生活了。
哦不，
王飞律是真的对你没有恶意啊，
我就是想帮你算清楚这笔账，
希望你能够理性的去啊做决策，
如果你的老公这个人，
第一啊，
他没有什么别的不良的嗜好，
第二呢，
他现在属于这个人生的低谷吗？
他曾经干过一年挣几十万的业务，
那证明他这个人能力还是在的，
你琢磨这件事情，
到底是陪着他度过这个低谷了之后翻身你日子好过一点，
还是说现在趁着他也不挣钱了啊，
趁着感情也不好了，
就脱身了，
你子好过一点，
你感觉好像都被他疯了，
可他不同意，
然他婚前的财产去第一套价是多少钱？
可能150万左右，
比如说把我们作为一个裁判者的这个角度的话，
大概率上也应该拿他婚前的房子去偿还，
原因是什么？
因为婚后这套房子不是他一个人的，
现在他欠的这个债是他一个人的，
他欠他前妻的这个债，
第一你没同意，
没签字，
第二这个债务没有用到你们两口子共同的生活当中，
那么基于这两点的话，
这笔债务就是叫做他的个人债务。
他的个。
人债务原则上就应该用他的个人财产去偿还，
而你们两口子这婚后的这套房不属于他的个人财产，
有没有先别着急，
这个你看看他的那个结果呗，
他打官司打出来的结果，
他有一个执行的过程，
大概率下，
那我的这个经验来谈的话，
大概率下就应该用他个人财产，
他婚前那套房去抵债，
他检他干嘛去了，
那他爸爸那个单位干干嘛，
房子已经过户到你老公名下了呀，
那就是你老公名下的财产了呀，
这个我明白，
我老公他现在的想法就是婚前那套房子是我公公婆婆在住，
他的想法就是他婚前的财产他不想住，
他就只想卖我的公后的那套房子，
婚后那个房子正好卖掉，
可能把他外面的债，
你想他前妻那里还一点，
然后他外面还欠了七八个，
给我再还掉，
就这样，
然后叫我去跟他们爸妈一起住，
他的想法是这种，
那我就不背意了，
你不乐意，
你别发脾气，
我们人有的时候就是人在屋檐下，
不得不低头，
我处在这样一个环境下，
第一，
我没有很高的赚钱的能力，
第二，
我爸爸妈妈帮不上我什么忙，
第三，
我有一个6岁的孩子在我身边，
第4，
我老公现在处于事业低谷，
在这种情况下，
你琢磨一下，
离不离得起这个婚，
如果说我们今天得出一个结论，
我离不起这个婚，
好，
这个婚老娘。
就是不离的，
在不离的情况下，
我怎么能够得到我想要的状态，
我现在想要的状态就是他去卖他婚前那套房，
然后住我们两口子婚后这套房，
对不对？
我可以退一步说，
我说可以把爸妈接到这边来住嘛，
这边比较宽敞一点，
爸妈住的也舒服一点，
爸妈的年纪都那么大了，
也让爸妈住好一点的，
这个环境好一点的房子。
再说了，
孩子在这里都住习惯了，
孩子的朋友都在这里，
孩子上学在这里多方便呀，
就是用各种方法去达到你想要的目的。